>>Male Presenter: Hi.
This is Zach Weinersmith.
Many of you may know him from Sunday Morning
Breakfast Cereal--the comic that he does.
He also does SMBC Theater and has a blog working
that will teach you in physics and calculus
from college.
And I don't know what else you're doing.
I don't know what you've handed out to the
crowd here or what we're in for.
[Zach Weinersmith laughs]
I'm sure you have some other experimental
project going on here.
>>Zach Weinersmith: Yes.
>>Male Presenter: All right, we'll go with
that.
Take it away.
I think this is, maybe talk a little bit about
yourself.
And I think this is mostly gonna be Q&A.
>>Zach Weinersmith: So, yeah.
I do two other projects.
I do "Snowflakes," a children's comic and
"Captain Stupendous," which is not at all
for children.
[audience chuckles] And the new thing I'm
doing with Breadpig, other than the books,
we have a book out.
We'll be debuting it at NYCC if any of you
are coming.
And we have, as you've seen, the world's first
single-use gentlemen’s unlubricated disposable
monocle.
[laughter]
And I wanted to talk about it 'cause it's
really cool just in terms of what it's like
to be a creator right now, which is--.
It started with, as you know, there's actually
a comic that was about this.
And the joke was that there's a lady asking
a guy if he had protection.
And surprisingly, he took out a monocle instead
of a condom.
[laughter]
And I'm very good at telling jokes live I
guess.
[laughter]
I should tell you.
>>MALE #1: Is that in there?
>>Zach Weinersmith: It might be too recent.
I don't know.
There's a funny thing about that one 'cause
there's a point in it where he puts on a monocle
and he's just pointing down.
That's his indication.
[laughter]
But my voting buttons are under my sharing
buttons, so he was actually pointing at reddit
and so, reddit got really excited about that.
[laughter]
But it was cool because--.
So, I had this idea and then it occurred to
me that we might actually be able to make
a monocle in a condom wrapper, which would
be like, the funniest thing ever.
[laughter] And so, I just put a post on my
blog, like, "Could anyone tell me how to accomplish
this 'cause I have no idea?"
And so, I got a couple offers from people
who thought they could put it together.
And then, it occurred to me that it might
be smart to try to get it done in a more traditional
way.
And I started looking into it.
And maybe some of you have been to a costume
shop and have seen the--.
You get these little rings of plastic.
They have really crummy.
There's no lens in them.
I don't know if anyone's opened one, but really,
it's like an actual monocle.
I mean, it's not a proper lens.
It's just a piece of acrylic.
So, don't try to see with it.
And also, it wouldn't be very unique.
I would've felt a little bad basically buying
someone else's product, unpackaging it, repackaging
it, and selling it.
And so, it turned out not only could I not
do it, I didn't want to do it if I could do
it.
And then, a guy named Ben Peters--we just
met with a minute ago.
He's at the Media Labs over at MIT.
Said he thought he could build these things.
And so, we gave him the go ahead and two weeks
later, he had sent me a prototype.
And it's a brass ring with an acrylic lens
and there's even a brass chain on it, which
is just magical.
And he even, the version I never touched happily,
which he sent me a picture of, was actually
lubricated.
[laughter]
And I think the only thing that's sad about
it is that it actually looked really cool.
It had a transparent bag, so there was just
this monocle floating in jelly.
[laughter]
But we figured maybe you don't want lubricant
in your eye.
I' haven't had that experience.
Maybe some of you have.
But so, we made an unlubricated version, which
is the one you have.
And it's cool because there was this nice
way where a whole bunch of us brought different
sets of skills together.
So, I had the stupid idea.
That's my skill.
But then, Breadpig is handling distribution.
And Kristine is local, so she was actually
able to talk to Ben about how these things
are gonna come out.
And then, Ben, who is at Media Labs, knows
how to build monocles with brass and a laser
cutter, and then also had to seal them in
Mylar.
And then, the art is by David Malki.
I don't know if any of you know--.
Yeah, OK.
So, he does comical Wondermark.
So we wanted to set a Victorian flavor and
do the essential Victorian comic.
And he has this awesome library of real Victorian
art that he's turned into vector art, so he
can use it for all sorts of cool products.
And so, we were really able to pull all these
different resources at once to make this really
cool product.
And I'm hoping to do this more.
I don't know what the stupid stuff will be
in the future, but it's a really cool time
now that you can just pool resources this
way.
So, I encourage you guys to do the same thing
with your stupid ideas.
[laughter]
So, yeah.
That's pretty much all I wanted to say about
the monocles.
I think they'll be out in October if everything
goes well.
And yeah.
So, does anyone have any questions?
I mostly wanted to do Q&A today.
[laughter]
>>MALE #2: So, just to talk about, do you
have to hand make all of the monocles?.
>>Zach Weinersmith: I'm just showing you the
process.
It essentially gets, although the way--.
He's working on automating it a little bit,
so the lens, for example, is laser cut.
So, it goes through and cuts all the lenses.
So, that part is easy.
And the way he does the rings is by hand,
though.
But it's not too bad.
He just basically has a tube and he forms
the ring, ties it off, and then has a little
adhesive to seal in the lens.
So, it's fairly simple.
But it's more complicated than it needs to
be.
So, I'm a little terrified that we'll actually
sell out of these, which would be really sad.
My wife completely rolled her eyes about this
project.
[laughter]
And the comic, actually.
She was like, "Don't do this.
It's stupid."
And then when I made the real thing, she was
like, "Don't do this.
It's stupid."
[laughter]
So, if it's a success, I win the relationship.
The question was answered?
Yeah, so it's--.
We're a little worried.
If it sells out--we were just talking about
this on the way over.
We're gonna have to figure out some way to
simplify or augment the process.
The problem is, and this is still the case,
if you want like a hundred of something it's
not so bad 'cause you can go to someone like
Ben, who can just make these things.
Our original load was gonna be a thousand
of them.
And if you want a million of them, you can
go to China.
But getting these intermediate levels is a
little trickier volume-wise.
You have to figure out.
We even thought that--.
We learned a lot of weird stuff.
So, we thought we could just send them the
monocles in a condom wrapper company could
just wrap them up.
It turns out, you're not supposed to use condom
wrapper machines for anything but condoms.
[laughter]
I can't imagine why.
>>MALE #3: Like, this is medical equipment
--.
>>MALE #4: Process glass on those things.
>>Zach Weinersmith: What?
>>Zach Weinersmith: Yes.
So, he's more or less making them by hand.
But with the Media Labs, it's a little nicer.
Yeah?
>>MALE #5: So, what percentage of your strips
does your wife look at and say, "This is stupid?"
[laughter]
>>Zach Weinersmith: I actually, I have like
a secret joke Congress that analyzes my jokes
before they go to my hand.
[laughter]
It's considered press, if that makes any sense.
So, she's actually, she's always responsive.
My friends don't have to respond, but she
has to 'cause she's the most sense.
And so, she reads every single joke.
She's actually the only one who reads every
single joke in advance.
It's nice because when she doesn't like a
joke and I do it, I can be like, "In your
face."
And when she likes a joke and I do and it
fails, it's also in her face.
[laughter]
It's really, I always win--win the relationship.
I think through the bonus comics, I make it
seem like she's always rolling her eyes at
the jokes, but I think she rolls her eyes--she's
a scientist, I should say.
She has real skills.
[laughter]
And so, she rolls her eyes at my life.
But in the actual comics, I think she likes
them OK because I was doing them before we
started dating.
And while I was dating, it became my test
for potential joke friends because if they
couldn't stomach the comic, they probably
couldn't stomach me.
And so, she at least liked them three years
ago.
[laughter]
Yeah?
>>MALE #6: Who's winning the relationship
now?
>>Zach Weinersmith: Who's winning?
I'm way ahead.
[laughter]
>>MALE #6: What if I asked her?
>>Zach Weinersmith: I don't know.
>>FEMALE #1: Last time we asked her, she was
like, "It's not a contest."
[laughter]
>>Zach Weinersmith: She may not recognize
it's a contest, but--.
I don't know.
I don't know if I believe her saying that.
That's the kind of thing a loser says.
[laughter]
>>MALE #7: Talk a little bit about your selection
process.
>>Zach Weinersmith: Yeah.
So, we were really overdue for a book 'cause
by the time we started looking through, there
were 21 hundred strips.
And I was originally gonna actually do just
one through 21 hundred.
I was like, "I have ten books worth of material."
And I was going through this and I was like,
"A lot of this is garbage."
And especially the early set.
You always hate your earlier work.
But I do think it's gotten better over time.
>>MALE #7: How far back in your stuff did
you go?
>>Zach Weinersmith: I think there are some
one's probably from the first weeks of it,
but not many.
Like, I probably actually tried, if you look
at the graph of how many I pulled per month
over time, it increases from something like
at least five percent up to 50 percent on
a really good month.
And then so, I went through and I had Kristina
and Alexis, who's also at Breadpig, my wife,
and a couple other close friends, would go
through and just tack off which ones they
liked.
And then I interpreted that along with what
I actually wanted.
And then my recollection of how it had done
on StumbleUpon or reddit or what people said
about it.
And I tried not to lean on that too much 'cause
there are comics that are, people like them,
but they don't link them.
You know what I mean?
And then, there are comics that people link
but don't like.
And so, I was trying to just get the really
good ones.
I was hoping that this book would reach out
to people who don't already own the comic.
Ideally, it's a book you can pick up and read
it and laugh at.
And that was pretty much it.
There was a little math.
And I hopefully selected the favorites.
And it's been pretty well received, I think.
I think I've get a few people saying, "You
left out my favorite comic."
But not too much.
>>MALE #8: You mentioned jokes falling flat.
How are you gauging how people react to your
jokes?
>>Zach Weinersmith: I probably shouldn't gauge
it at all.
That's my fault.
What I basically do--let me think about that.
I know that's why I run them by a couple people
first.
And they actually just give me letter grades,
like, "This is a B minus."
And that sort of thing.
And once I run through that, then I put it
up.
And I think what I probably used to gauge
is how Breadpig reacts to it because they're
a pretty egalitarian community.
They don't have power users.
And then, how many re-tweets and how it gets
out in Twitter.
And there's a little more data you can get
through like, looking at your analytics and
stuff.
But it is not exactly a science.
But you can kinda tell.
You can at least tell the ones that have done
very well.
And so, I try to actually do a lot of feedbacks.
Most people are opposed to that.
They think it's a diminution of the artistic
something or other, but I think the way you
improve is by figuring out what people like.
Yeah?
>>MALE #9: Is there ever the case that one
of your reviewers grade something A and another
one grades F?
And then if so, what does the comic actually
do?
>>Zach Weinersmith: I've only ever gotten
one F. And that was when someone was mad at
me.
[laughter]
It wasn't my wife.
I'll tell you that.
She's given me a D before.
But yeah.
It's actually very common.
What I try to do to marginalize that is I
try to make the comic as abstract as possible,
which is to say, if there's a character who's
a dad in the comic, but you might not read
that from the visual, I just say like "older
man" or something.
And so, I try to make it so the individuals,
as much as possible, will just react to the
joke and not anything I'm not gathering.
Because it is scary.
And then I have ones where I'm like, "This
is gold.
This is solid gold."
And someone else is like, "C plus."
And I also, you can, after you work with someone
for a while, you can learn to find their blind
spots and their inverse blind spots.
I don't have a good word for it.
But like, my wife will always laugh at biology
jokes no matter how crappy it is.
And like, I have a friend who is really into
Gundam.
He'll laugh at any giant robot jokes.
So, I don't trust him much.
[laughter]
And so, I don't know if anyone's done this,
but I wanna set up a really cool audience
feedback mechanism this way.
So, the way it's done now is you basically
hire a bunch of people--like, you wanna see
if they like a movie.
You go to your local area.
Hire 200 people and get them to rate it.
I think it would be a much better system if
you just set up a market and you said, "This
person is usually right about this type of
movie.
This person is usually right about this type.
And when this person says this type of movie
is bad, it's actually good."
And you can run much smarter math on it.
And I've been half-tempted to do it on my
own little--.
I think I have seven people right now.
I could probably do this and then I backed
away from it.
I was like, "This is gonna get too obsessive
and I'm not gonna be writing my own comic
anymore."
[laughter]
But someone at some point, if they haven't
already, is gonna go that.
I think it would be a really cool project.
But yeah, you have to learn to know what kind
of feedback you're getting from individuals
'cause people have really big blind spots
sometimes.
>>MALE #10: That could also be useful data
for your readers, though, if they see, "Oh,
if this is one that she liked, then--
>>Zach Weinersmith: That's a good point--
>>MALE #10: "I'll read these and skip the
ones that--."
>>Zach Weinersmith: Yeah, kind of the archive
bits.
That's not a bad idea.
We're actually working on like, a tag system,
but I don't know.
It scares me, the idea that I could set something
like, just tag all the science comics and
then someone would come through and they would
only read the science comics.
'Cause I like to try--.
Part of the fun of it is exposing people to
new stuff they'd never seen and I worry that
I would be allowing people too much freedom.
[laughter]
>>MALE #10: That's just how you get them hooked.
>>Zach Weinersmith: Yeah.
That might be true.
We've actually talked about it.
One of the other cool things from a business
standpoint is you could sell them the magazines,
that sort of thing.
You do jokes only about dogs.
I have like, four comics about dogs.
But not yet.
Yeah?
>>MALE #11: Can you tell about your creative
process a little bit?
>>Zach Weinersmith: Yeah.
>>MALE #11: Do you just sit in a room and
think of hilarious stuff?
[laughter]
>>Zach Weinersmith: I wish.
It's not too far from it.
What I do is--.
I was actually just talking to Alexis about
this at the wedding the other day.
She had some questions.
And what my philosophy about doing creative
work is this.
I think most people think the way you do creative
work is that you just sit down and try to
be creative, right?
I think it really just doesn't work.
That's not the way your brain is set up.
Your brain is set up to formulate lots of
ideas, different combinations, and then, a
really good creator is someone who is A, good
at coming up with lots of ideas and then B,
editing and shaping those.
And taking the bad ones from the good ones.
And so, it might seem like a small distinction,
but I think which way you believe on that
question affects the way you handle your workload.
So, if you believe that just being creative
is just a thing you do, you would probably
just try to do that a lot.
You would sit down and be like, "It's creative
time."
And I think it's really ineffective.
And that's why we have these terms like "writer's
block" that I'm convinced is just a made-up
term for not doing your homework.
And when I say that, it really pisses people
off.
[laughter]
So, if you believe that your job is to synthesize
ideas that you already have, or come up with
new combinations, then what you should do
with your time is not trying to write.
It should be trying to intake as much information
as possible.
So, on a given day for me, I spend at least,
say, ten hours learning various, different
stuff.
And I, for example, I read books that I find
boring because it's new information.
Most people don't because they don't need
to, you know what I mean?
They read stuff they find exciting.
So, I read in areas I'm not interested in
and I'll read older books and I try to read
stuff other people aren't reading and try
to read a lot of variety.
Like you were saying, I do these calculus
and physics blogs, but I also read "literature"
and philosophy and history and pretty much,
I think, literally everything.
There aren't too many subjects I won't do,
like cookbooks or fashion or something.
But pretty much anything that would make me
look snooty at a party I will read.
And so, I think really, what I would say is
I think the creative process is really more
about making yourself more interesting, having
more of a perspective.
You shouldn't try to just cultivate being
good at "creativity" because it's not a real
thing.
It would be a better use of your time--.
I would even say, I think the way to say this
is the equation for doing good work is not
a simple linear equation.
You will get more good work done if you spend,
say, 15 hours in your day reading and then
one hour writing than you will spending 16
hours a day writing because you won't have
all those ideas you need to do good work.
Yeah.
>>MALE #12: So, at what point of the idea
generation process do you say, "This is an
SMBC idea" versus "This is a blog post" versus--?
>>Zach Weinersmith: Right.
Right.
I would say all the projects I work on right
now are different enough that the mindset
is different.
I would say I do believe most of your time
should be spent reading, but when I do creative
work, usually I sit down and do a particular
task . So, with SMBC though, you're still
parsing lots of ideas, right?
So, with SMBC, it would be just trying to
come up with really anything, which is the
good and bad of it.
Whereas like, if I'm writing script for something--I
have a couple other projects I'm working on
that are long.
For one, a Choose Your Own Adventure for Breadpig.
And so that's a different process.
That's more about being clever.
And that's a little, in a sense, it's harder
to train.
That takes a little more time, I guess.
I don't know.
I try to come up with a little word play sort
of things instead of just writing paragraphs.
So, yeah.
I don't have a lot of--.
It's not as if I come up with something and
then I'm like, "Where does this fit?"
It's usually a little more circumscribed.
. Yeah.
>>MALE #13: Have you ever heard from Sarah
Silverman or her camp?
>>Zach Weinersmith: No.
She stole my joke.
You're the only one in the room who knows
what I'm talking about.
[laughter]
I, she didn't actually steal my joke.
I did a joke maybe five years ago-- I can't
believe it's been a long time--about--.
The nice thing about comics is I can hide
behind the paper and not have to tell offensive
jokes in person.
But here it goes.
The joke was that you can solve AIDS in Africa
by dropping Playstations on Africa.
And then it was weird 'cause I had done this
joke and like, weeks later, Sarah Silverman
was at some--.
She'd done some sort of gaming award show
and she was doing stand-up comedy.
And I think it was apparently not liked well
because she made fun of video game players.
But she did basically the exact same joke,
like, "We'll solve the crisis in Africa by
giving them video games."
And so, I did this fake media of me demanding
that she remove the joke immediately because
I'm the only one who's ever made an AIDS joke.
[laughter]
And she never called me back.
So, no.
Nothing.
But I did make a fake mean Sarah Silverman
dating video like with clips of her and clips
of me.
It was really creepy.
[laughter]
So, we've basically talked about it.
Yeah?
>>MALE #14: Can you give us like, the origin
story of SMBC?
>>Zach Weinersmith: Yeah.
I didn't think I called it SMBC since about
1998 when I was like, 16.
But it was a really different thing.
If you click the archive button on the website,
you can actually see some of the really like,
from maybe 2000, 2001--the older stuff I did,
which was a very cliché like, three panel,
friends hanging out sort of comic.
It was less cliché back then than it is now,
but it was pretty cliché then.
And I think I was doing it just as a joke.
Like, I was really just making fun of friends,
which is why I only had friends before I knew
anything about web comics.
And at some point in college, I figured I
could maybe do this for a living.
So, I started looking into it a little harder.
And I switched it doing single panels 'cause
I--maybe other people write differently from
what I do, but the nice thing about writing
for characters is you just see what they do,
whereas coming up with
a whole glove joke, you have to start from
the beginning.
But I was finding that I could come up with
jokes that I wanted to do and no characters
could reasonably say them.
And so, I basically had a cast of 20 main
characters and it was just not cool.
And so, I switched to doing single panels.
And it was a good lesson 'cause I only had
like, two or three hundred readers then.
And I still got complaints from switching
formats, like it was the end of my "career"
that I would switch formats.
And it's stupid because I do meet people who
have--, they're doing web comics and they
have just like a few readers and they want
to switch to something better and they won't
do it 'cause they don't want to disappoint
the couple people reading.
And it's just a mistake to not allow yourself
that leeway.
But then, I actually quit again in college
and I was working a terrible, horrible job
for talent agents in Hollywood.
It was really horrible [chuckles].
And I remember, very specifically, I'd just
shown them my comic and--finally, after working
there for six months--and I had the opportunity.
And I heard one of my bosses, who I don't
want to say was an idiot, but once asked me--.
She called me in her room and says, "What
does this word punny--?
What does punny mean?"
P-U-N-Y.
[laughter]
And so, she calls me to her office to talk
about the comics and she said to me, "The
problem with your generation [laughter] is
that you're always starting things and never
finishing them.
And imagine where you would be if you had
done this for five years."
And I instantly thought, "I would be anywhere
else."
[laughter]
And that sounded great.
And so, as I remember--I might be mythologizing
this a little--I think that night I actually
started doing daily updates again.
And I basically kept that going.
I missed a few here and there, but pretty
much, yeah.
>>MALE #15: Do you keep a queue like, ahead
of time?
Like how many comics do you keep queued up?
>>Zach Weinersmith: I'm queued up through
tomorrow night when I fly home.
[laughter]
I normally don't.
I occasionally get a little ahead, but I actually--.
The traditional cartoon, some of them are
ahead by like, a year, which it's cool that
they do that in the newspapers and need them
to do it, but I just feel like that's a good
way to not be in tune with what's going on.
I mean, I don't do topical jokes.
I feel like you still need to be living in
your own time.
I mean, if you're doing Ziggy, I guess it
just doesn't matter.
I think Ziggy is still running.
I shouldn't say that.
[laughter]
If you're doing Peanuts--
>>MALE #16: Yeah, how do you tell--
>>Zach Weinersmith: Yeah.
But so, I--.
Maybe I'm just excusing my own behavior, but
I don't think I would ever want to be more
than, say, a week ahead.
I'm actually a week ahead this week because
of, I'm doing stuff on the East Coast.
But I do keep a writing buffer.
But the actual art, not as much.
And partially, that's because, as you know,
I'm doing a lot of projects at once.
But also, I actually usually get uncomfortable.
A few times, I've been a week ahead and I
just feel weird.
I feel like I'm not in touch with what I'm
doing with the audience.
I think most web cartoons, I think probably
because of that phenomenon or not--I hit on
that word--there's no reason we should be
less ahead than the print people other than
they're obligated to for legal reasons.
So, basically I don't.
Yeah.
>>MALE #17: So, are there any other, what
other web comic types do you particularly
say, admire or despise?
[laughter]
>>Zach Weinersmith: Admire.
There are comics that are really good.
The one's I like to read, though, are one's
I feel I can learn something from.
So like, one I really like actually--.
Have you ever read Buttersafe?
You guys know about that one?
It's not super popular, but I learn a lot
from it.
And I remember I was talking to Randy from
"XKCD" about this.
He was like, "Oh, Buttersafe, because he's
always doing big ideas."
And that's what's good about it.
The problem with doing big ideas and being
more artsy is that nine times out of ten,
it's not as fun to read.
It's just weird or obscure, whatever it is.
But it's nice because now that he does something
that really nobody else could do, or they
do--it's two guys--and so that's an example
of something where, in terms of day to day
reading, it's not my favorite, but I feel
like I'm picking up ideas from it.
I feel a little that way about "XKCD" , or
at least he paved the way for nerdy comedy
to go mainstream.
And I've read some more obscure comics like
there was a comic first starting called "The
Parking Lot is Full."
It's--.
You read it?
OK.
Yeah.
I think it's been defunct since 2002 or something.
It's been ages.
But it's almost hard to appreciate now because
web comics have really developed since those
days, but it was so abrasive for a comic.
It would like, it would be single panels and
the captions would yell at you, the reader.
[audience chuckles] It was weird stuff.
Even a comic like the "Far Side," which broke
down a lot of barriers, it's still very traditional
and presents a situation and then elaborates
on it a little.
That's a traditional caption comic.
And these were really interesting 'cause they
would maybe do something else completely differently
or digress from the topic or would have captions
like this long.
And it's kinda the same deal, maybe you feel
the same way.
"The Parking Lot is Full" on a day to day
basis maybe wasn't solid gold, but was really
doing new, interesting stuff.
And so, that's the kind of comic I like.
Like, I have other comics I really love, like
I love a comic called "Amazing Super Powers."
But he's kinda in the same space as I am,
so I don't feel like we probably couldn't
learn from each other.
So, there wouldn't be much creative use for
us to read each other’s comics.
And then there's Dale Beran's "A Lesson is
Learned but the Damage is Irreversible."
That was a really good comic.
Sort of the same deal with pushing what you
could do with a comic.
That's what I liked reading.
But I actually don't read that many comics.
There are very few that I actually read.
Do you have a follow-up question?
OK.
Do you have a question?
>>MALE #18: Actually, I had the exact same
question.
[laughter]
>>MALE #19: What software do you use to do
the drawing and coloring?
>>Zach Weinersmith: I use nice, but pretty
much standard card stock paper--regular ream
of paper.
And then, I draw in a non-photographic blue
pencil that doesn't scan.
And then, I just use a plain, black ink marker
and then I scan into Photoshop and color.
It's really very simple.
There's nothing--.
I actually, when people ask me, like other
artists ask me, I hope not to do it my way
because almost everyone I know has tablets
now.
I just can't do it.
I probably will eventually, but it just feels
weird.
And the way you have to draw in a tablet--.
Maybe there are tablet masters I haven't met,
but like, when I wanna do a line stroke, I
draw it.
And on the tablet, you have your hand on control
Z all the time, 'cause you have to draw everything
a couple time to get the stroke right.
It's not for me.
Anyone?
I brought some pictures.
[laughter]
>>MALE #20: It seems that the web comic industry
is pretty well-connected in terms of authors
knowing each other.
>>Zach Weinersmith: Oh, yeah.
>>MALE #20: Can you talk a little bit about
that and what that's like?
>>FEMALE#2: Tell us about your weekend.
>>Zach Weinersmith: Yeah, yeah.
I was actually at a wedding and Dinosaur Comics
was there, and Wondermark was there, and TopatoCo
was there.
Questionable Content was there.
>>MALE #20: So, you were in the happy battle.
>>Zach Weinersmith: Yes.
It was a beautiful place.
We actually have a lot of private channels--the
web comic artists do.
I was talking to Kristine about this.
If you've been reading web comics for a long
time, you probably remember up to something
like 2007, there was a lot more public fighting
and drama between web cartoonists.
Now, there's not much.
And the reason is 'cause it happens in private.
[laughter]
But it's cool.
This will probably go away over the next,
say, generation.
But right now is a really cool time because
everyone who is doing web comics professionally
really know pretty much everyone else because
we all go to the same conventions.
We share the same data 'cause we have to run--.
Everyone has a slightly different business
model, but it's essentially the same.
So it's like if you wanna, like the ad setup
I have right now.
I got it from Chris Hallbeck, who does a comic
called "The Book of Biff."
And it's really helpful in having that shared
pooled knowledge.
For me, just having his advice on that ad
setup has, over time, doubled my income--just
doing it properly.
And so, yeah.
There's just a lot of talk.
And pretty much everyone knows each other.
And what's really nice is because everyone
has bootstrapped their way up to their position--there's
no other way to do it, I guess--and so everyone
essentially is a small business owner.
So, there's not a lot of BS with people.
And it's also easier to be friends when you
don't need each other.
Everyone's an idol in web comics.
And so, it's usually very chummy at conventions.
There are a few crazy people, but I won't
say.
[laughter]
>>MALE #21: How much time do you have to spend
on the business side of things, like with
the ads?
>>Zach Weinersmith: It's not too bad.
Just this year, I was getting to where I was
like, having physiological symptoms from stress
and not sleeping this year.
And so, I finally gave in and I have two people
who help me out now.
So, in terms of store stuff and fulfillment,
I have a person who handles all the shipping,
order-taking.
I don't even want to look at it anymore.
And I have a guy who is more local to me and
he helps out with simple Photoshop jobs and
just little stuff--just random things.
And so, at this point it's--I'm gonna tell
you--I at least get to do something like 80
to 90 percent nonbusiness.
And there's stuff that's like when you count
like designing stuff in a book or picking
comics, it's a little--.
Some of it's iffy.
But the really not fun stuff, like mailing
and handling my ad chain, I don't really touch
anymore, which is amazing.
But I really feel like I think this year has
been much better.
I have much more pride in my work this year.
And I think, in large part, it's because I've
had people taking slack.
I haven't had to just do something at the
last minute because I didn't want to.
And so, yeah.
That's been really cool.
I think the future of web comics is going
to be that--and this is already forming--there
will be something like the old agency system,
like the big literary agency system in place
now.
It'll take care of this stuff for you.
It hasn't really existed yet, but Breadpig
is in that space and they're the best edit.
And TopatoCo is in that space and Blind Ferret
is in that space now.
And my hope is that essentially what will
happen is that the agency system will get,
will basically become what it was originally,
just not run by assholes, [chuckles] which
really would make a difference.
What I mean by that, to be specific, the difference
between me being with a traditional company
and me being with Breadpig in terms of what
my take is and how much control I have is
night and day.
So, if I were to say, be with Random House
or something, I would have to--.
They would be able to tell me to change my
cover if they wanted to.
They could edit content.
They could make demands about what had to
go in.
And they would give, just money-wise, a much
smaller cut.
I think it's not quite an order of magnitude,
but it's in that ball park.
I've done traditional publishing and I probably
will never do it again because what ends up
happening is the only way you can make a living
out of it is if you sell something like a
hundred thousand copies.
And most people aren't gonna do that.
Whereas, I know people who have audiences,
like under ten thousand people, who make a
living at it because the cut is good enough.
And they can handle their own market.
And so, I hope the old publishing universe
is turning this way.
In my little bubble, everything is going this
way.
In the web comics world it definitely is,
but I hope that publishing in general--book
publishing, and traditional comic book publishing--will
go that way.
Yeah.
>>MALE #22: [clears throat] How does that
tie in with how "Machine of Death" went out?
>>Zach Weinersmith: Oh, "Machine of Death."
That was awesome.
If you guys don't know, "Machine of Death"--I
wasn't involved in this, just to be clear--.
No, I don't involved in that project.
That was Malki.
I'm happy to talk about it.
I know what happened.
Malki and Ryan North, Dinosaur Comics and
Wondermark, they did a very simple idea for
a project.
And it's interesting if you think about it
in comparison to what a publishing house basically
does.
They were doing the same thing.
They said, "We need a bunch of short stories
and art work.
We're gonna compile it together and the only
thing we're gonna do is that it has every
story has to have this theme of a machine
that--what was it?--it knows when you're going
to die."
>>MALE #22: It tells you how you're gonna
die.
>>Zach Weinersmith: It tells you how you're
gonna die, that's right.
And so, every short story could be anything.
It just had to have this theme in it.
And so, they actually put together this really
good book of stories.
And what was really cool was I'd never seen
this done and we actually ended up doing this
with Captain Stupendous, a book I released,
where you--if you're selling it through Amazon.
Say you're selling it from Amazon.
You tell everyone, "Don't buy until the day
I tell you."
And then you can run up the numbers, exactly.
So, they actually hit number one for one day,
which was extra cool 'cause they displaced
Glenn Beck for one day.
[laughter]
And Glenn Beck--this is true--actually went
on TV and said, "There's this book called
'Machine of Death' and it's the liberal culture
of death at work."
[laughter]
And which was, of course, stupid 'cause they
sold so many books after that.
Everyone's like, "We pissed off Glenn Beck?
This is great."
And yeah.
That was a really good example of how just
by having a good relationship with your audience,
like--think about it this way.
If you were doing Batman, you might not be
able to pull that off because Ryan North can
directly talk to 50 thousand people and Malki
can, too.
And so, if you can just mobilize ten thousand
people to do the same thing at the same time,
you can get really cool results.
Whereas, something like Batman doesn't have
that personal relationship.
You read it 'cause you wanna know what Batman's
up to.
You don't care--.
You probably care who the author is, but not
in the same way you do with Dinosaur Comics,
where you feel like you know the guy.
And that's one of the cool things that web
comics can do that I think a lot of the older
comics are now clumsily trying to get into
that universe.
But I actually hope they succeed 'cause it
makes everything more fun when you can interact
with all these people.
>>MALE #23: So, how do you decide what fraction
of your time to spend on all of your different
projects?
>>Zach Weinersmith: Yeah.
It's actually like I was saying earlier.
The equation isn't simple in the sense that--.
You can fallow the fields, so to speak.
So, the part of your brain that does calculus
is not the part of your brain writes dirty
jokes.
And so for me, what I try to do is I'll work
on something until I'm about tired of it,
unless I'm on a deadline.
Then, I have to make things work.
But I'll work on calculus until I just can't
take it anymore.
And it's actually good 'cause calculus, it's
very logical, it's very rigorous, it's very
step by step.
Whereas doing comics is the opposite.
So, what I've done when I'm being good, is
I actually have a daily schedule that says
"from 9 to 11 you will do math" and then "from
11 to 11:30 try to write three jokes" and
then "from 11:30 to 12:30" I don't know.
I can float my schedule.
But I stole the idea from Ben Franklin.
It was in his autobiography.
[laughter]
He had this book.
He was like, "I'm too lazy.
I have to do more stuff."
So, he scheduled his whole life.
You don't realize how much time you're spending
poking around the internet until you schedule
your life.
And it's amazing what you can get done in
16 hours if you are not doing anything else.
It's also, because it's fun, it's not so bad.
I do work on--.
It's also good 'cause my wife is also crazy
about her work, so there's no awkwardness
or no "why don't we do out more often?"
It's usually by the time we go out, we both
want it.
And so, that's been realized.
I honestly don't know what I would do if I
were with someone who wanted me to take her
out on weekends.
[laughter]
But, yeah.
More often than not, I want to go out before
she does.
Yeah?
>>MALE #24: Who are the people who do SMBC
Theater?
Are they just your friends, or how did you
meet them?
>>Zach Weinersmith: So, James, the other guy
who writes, I've known him since high school.
He's actually one of the characters in my
old comic strip.
And we, for ages, wanted to do video projects.
And then, it just happened that there was
a nice situation where I had built up a little
audience and had a tiny amount of disposable
income that I could put to work some new projects.
And then, he had just moved to LA.
He's a graduate of the Carnegie Mellon screen-writing
program, which meant he had this network of
people for us to abuse.
[audience chuckles] And so, it was cool.
So, I could finance this and do the publicity
and, of course, help with the writing.
And then he was able to bring almost all of
our actors are alumni of that program.
Which is extra nice because they bring more
people 'cause they have this just crazy network
of people.
So, it was very rare that we were wanting
for actors or actresses once we got going,
which is really cool since we only pay a few
people.
We only pay people who are doing technical
work, like work you just cannot get away with
not paying.
But most actors are willing to work for free
on publicity stuff.
So, we help them with their reels when they
want to put that together.
And I do believe in paying people, but we
weren't making a profit.
So, you suit your budget to the company, if
that makes sense.
But yeah, most of the people worked through
that network of people.
We had a few people we just found through
a friend of a friend of a friend.
But mostly it's graduate students.
I love them.
Yeah?
>>MALE #25: Are you ever worried you're getting
typecast?
You and James?
>>Zach Weinersmith: Special strikes.
>>MALE #26: You play Jesus a lot.
[laughter]
>>Zach Weinersmith: I was really sad when
I knew I didn't have long hair, so I had to
get a wig.
It was embarrassing.
>>MALE #28: You have long hair, now.
>>Zach Weinersmith: I know.
Yeah, yeah.
We are actually moving out of this new project
now where we're doing--.
We have a bunch of SMBC Theaters still in
the queue that we're still editing together
to put out.
But I'm actually, I don't love acting.
I enjoy it while I'm there, but comics are
awesome because on a good day it's in the
morning I have a good idea.
That evening I go home and I draw it.
It's this whole little universe thing idea
that I show to people.
And it probably takes me--.
Even that crazy one, like the 57-panel one
that was like eight hours.
It was a long time, but it wasn't crazy.
Whereas, acting in a video is an entire day
of your life.
And that doesn't count the writing or anything.
And then, you won't see project over for a
month and it's just the input/output ratio--it's
not great.
And so, I'm trying to get more into the backseat
of everything, help with the writing, make
creative choices, but not much on screen stuff.
I also, it got to where I was living in college
towns 'cause I followed my wife's research.
And it got to where I couldn't walk around
campus 'cause people know what I look like.
[laughter]
And I remember we were in Davis, California
and saw a guy wearing like, a scarf and a
hat in the summer.
That was me.
[laughter]
I don't have a problem meeting people, it's
just I was going to get work done and I get
stopped every 20 minutes to talk to someone.
It got pretty awkward after a while.
And it throws off your conversation to have
someone you don't know yell your name all
of a sudden.
But it's cool, too.
So once--this is cool--Kelly and I were walking
home, just from the library.
A guy walks by, just does not break his gait,
just keeps walking.
As he goes, he shouts, "You rock."
[laughter]
And that was OK.
If every interaction was like that, I could
do it.
But yeah, I'm not worried about typecasting
'cause I don't wanna be an actor.
Perhaps James should worry, he definitely
wants to--, but I mean, we're hoping to be
in a position where we control the productions.
So, if he felt he was typecast, he could write
himself a new character who was dashing and
heroic.
[laughter]
>>MALE #29: So, what's the most interesting,
or the most famous person you've interacted
with via somebody randomly knowing you're
a web comic?
>>Zach Weinersmith: I've had two really awesome
interactions.
The best one I ever had was--.
Just, I mean, I didn't get to meet him, but
I did this comic once that was about time
travel.
The joke was about a guy who wants meet other
time travelers, so he has the best party ever
and then everyone comes at the same time.
So, there's this singularity that kills everyone
who would ever want to time travel.
And that's why time travel is impossible.
[laughter]
And so, just whenever I have a scientist character
and it makes sense to, I will just pick a
scientist I actually really like and put them
in the character.
So, I had Kip Thorne, who many of you know
is a famous physicist.
He has his name on an equation or a theory
with Stephen Hawking, so he did all right
for himself.
[laughter]
And he's still at Caltech.
He still works.
And I think he's probably in his 70s or 80s.
So, I had done this comic and just didn't
think anything of it 'cause when I do younger
people, I expect maybe they'll get in touch
with me 'cause they might hear about it.
But Kip Thorne doesn't need to care about
comics.
Actually, no one needs to care about comics.
But then I found out it was his 70th or 80th
birthday.
Someone had printed this up and they had put
it out for him.
It was like, at Kip Thorne's birthday party.
It was the coolest thing ever.
And then he sent me a letter.
It wasn't like a personal "I love you."
That would've been cool . But it was just
like, "I really appreciated your comic.
Signed, Kip Thorne."
And I was like, "This I just don't deserve.
This is ludicrous."
That was really amazing.
It was especially good 'cause it was--.
My dad graduated with his PhD from Caltech
and so I can be like, "Guess who I got a letter
from.
I wonder if you knew him."
I triangulated between my dad and Kip Thorne
to see if they'd ever passed each other in
the hallways and we couldn't figure out that
he had, sadly.
But it's almost certain they did, which was
just kinda neat.
The other cool thing was I was at Comic Con--this
was like two years ago--and I was talking
to Phil Plait.
Maybe you know he does the Bad Astronomy blog
and we're like lame internet buddies now.
That's really precious.
I thought I should tell this.
He has a filthy sense of humor in person.
Just disgusting.
You can't do it publicly, so I get all of
it.
[laughter]
Don't tell him I said that.
But he's really cool.
And he, as you know, is really into a lot
media stuff.
And so, he actually came by my booth and we
just were chit chatting.
I think it was the first time we met in person.
And just at the exact same moment, Will Wheaton
came up to be like, "I love your comics."
I was like, "This is the greatest."
[laughter]
And there's actually a photo of me and Will
Wheaton and Phil Plait making faces at a camera.
And then there's a guy who photo bombed it,
which is really weird.
Especially 'cause Phil was actively trying
to photo bomb his own photo and this guy totally
one-upped him.
[laughter]
But that was really cool just from a nerd
standpoint.
Like, the Kip Thorne thing was actually gratifying
in a self-actualization sort of way, but Will
Wheaton and Phil Plait just dorking out was
awesome.
And at Comic Con, no less.
So, yeah.
I'd say those are my two favorite interactions.
I've had like, awkward interactions, but nothing
to be proud of.
>>MALE #30: There's one comic in here, I can't
find it again, which I believe had the old
Neil deGrasse Tyson and Phil Plait involved.
>>Zach Weinersmith: Yeah.
I haven't reached Neil deGrasse--.
It's become my way to--.
Like I hear about someone think they're cool.
I can touch base with them by doing the comic.
It's like, everyone like to be drawn.
And I haven't gotten Neil deGrasse Tyson . And
I've done two comics about him.
And he won't get in touch with me.
We should be best friends.
[laughter]
It's been nice.
I've had times when I--.
Well, Kip Thorne is the best example.
I've had other professors I've met just through
the comics and I could be like, "I was having
trouble with my physics homework and could
you help me with this?"
[laughter]
I actually did that once.
A friend of mine, Sean Carroll, he wrote a
book called "From Eternity to Here," and he
does a blog called Cosmic Variance.
And when I was just first learning physics,
he was a fan of the comic and we--.
Now when I have a problem--.
I would never ask him like, "Solve this equation
for me."
'Cause he's a professor at Caltech.
That might be rude.
[laughter]
But I would be like, "I really can't understand
this concept.
Could you help me with it?"
He was actually really nice.
He would write paragraphs to me.
It was really cool.
And so, that's the really nice, unexpected
side effects of doing cartoons.
And what's really cool, too, similarly, is
I'm learning something in math and I have
trouble with a definition or a problem or
something, I'll push it on Twitter and I will
get 18 answers in ten seconds.
It's really amazing.
>>MALE #31: How many of them are correct?
[laughter]
>>Zach Weinersmith: That is the problem.
What's more interesting is usually it's 90
percent correct.
There are people who are wrong, but what's
really interesting is you will ask a question
and you will say, "Why is this so?"
I'll give you an example I did recently.
I was doing these calculus blogs and what's
nice about it is I'm figuring out all the
things I never actually learned but felt like
I knew.
So, as you probably remember from a long time
ago, inverse trigonometrical functions have
a restricted domain.
And it's very reasonable to make a restricted
domain 'cause otherwise the math doesn't work.
But you suspect there must be an intuitive
reason why this might be the case.
And so, I went to Twitter and I said, "Can
anyone--."
Of course, I understood why you restrict the
domain for the math part.
That's the obvious part.
Everyone understands that instantly.
But why should it be in a human intuitive
way?
And so, I go to Twitter and I'm like, "Hey,
could anyone give me an insight on this?"
And instantly, it was 40 people saying that
you have to restrict the domain so the math
works.
And I was like--.
That's kind of boggling 'cause that means
most of the people who are interacting with
this type of math are not even trying to have
a deeper understanding of it.
But I got a couple of people who gave me other
ways to understand how it would work.
And actually, the best version of it I read--and
there were a couple of them--was if you imagine
a non-inverse trig function, it also has a
restricted range because of where it can go.
So, I thought that was the best way to think
of it, is to think of inverting it.
And so, it was neat to think about how--or
it was maybe scary to think about many people
who are actually doing this math don't have
I guess what I would call an understanding
of it.
They have a pragmatic understanding of it,
which is probably enough.
But in terms of insight, they didn't.
But that's what's cool about Twitter.
You can instantly, just by all the other people
telling me I was stupid, I can get some really
cool insights.
So, yeah.
Yeah?
>>MALE #32: I know you guys were thinking
of taking SMBC Theater and doing something
bigger with it.
What's the new format?
>>Zach Weinersmith: What we're doing, James
wrote a sketch.
I was involved with it, mostly doing punch
up, like fixing jokes and rearranging structure
stuff.
But we wrote the script.
It's sort of science fictiony, I don't know
how to say it.
It's like a comedy science fiction sitcom.
I don't want to say sitcom, 'cause that makes
it sound like the jokes are in any way tame,
but it's written by James, so it's just horrifying.
[laughter]
And so, that's the main thing we're working
on.
And that's what the bulk of the kick starter
money is going to.
Since we went so over, we're gonna try to
reward the people who took us above and beyond
by working on some additional projects that
we can give them basically for no kick starter
money.
Well, for their money, but for money they
were intending to give us that we can already
do on a smaller budget.
And so, we have a couple of things in the
pipe, but nothing that's developed enough
that's worth talking about.
I have a couple other projects.
Like I was saying, I'm working on a Choose
Your Own Adventure.
I have a couple book projects I'm doing, which
maybe at some point will get adapted into
something new production-wise.
But right now, our big focus is this science
fiction thing.
Pretty fun.
>>MALE #33: Were you the terrible temp agency
Choose Your Own Adventure thing here?
>>Zach Weinersmith: No, I've never done one.
>>MALE #33: OK.
>>Zach Weinersmith: I'm actually doing--Kristine
and I were talking about this--there's a lot
of weird math that goes into designing Choose
Your Own Adventure, like the flow-charting.
'Cause I stupidly, 'cause I knew this math,
I completely screwed it up.
I started--.
The way I'd been doing it, is I flow chart
in the abstract what a story should be like
and then I assign stuff to the scenes.
And if you wanna have a bridge, a fork, at
every point, you want to have a choice at
every point, you have to--.
It's two to the N plus one plus two to the
N plus one.
So, by the time you've gotten to two to the
tenth, which is to say you've only read ten
scenes, you have something like 15 hundred
scenes you have to write to make the reader
able to do that, right?
So, you have to figure out a reasonable, but
still fun, way to clip.
So, the cool thing is if you clip at a branch,
you clip off two to the N from that point,
right?
Two to the N plus two to the N plus one and
so on.
And so, it's not as scary if you just learn
how to clip judiciously.
But so, there is, it's an interesting thing
and you can even look at flow charts and you
can tell the genre.
I don't mean a genre like whether it's a Western
or not, but there's a genre of whether it's
a what type of story they're telling from
just looking at the flow chart.
So like, the old Choose Your Own Adventure
that you read when you were 12, the little
simple one that actually says "Choose Your
Own Adventure" on the top, the flowchart,
you could make it fan out in every direction
'cause there are lots of short stories with
choices.
In fact, it might even be two to the N plus
two to the N plus one and so on, because you
really basically have a simple fork at each
point.
And to get to the end might only be ten steps.
And the way you play this is you try to do
all the different routes, right?
Whereas, if--.
So, if you look at the flow chart, it would
either look like that or it would look like
a fat triangle, right?
Whereas, if it was a game book--.
I don't know if you played gaming Choose Your
Own Adventure.
There a slightly different genre where you
can interact with your setting and fight stuff
and you can pick up things.
It's like D and D for one.
[laughter]
I've seen a couple of these games.
There's a very popular one--
>>MALE #33: If you pick up the sword three
steps ago, then--
>>Zach Weinersmith: It's exactly like that,
yeah.
And what's interesting though is to make that
work, you have to have a much more linear
flow because you're telling one story, right?
And also, if it's stuff like you have to have
the sword to kill the whatever, you have to
actually get the sword.
Otherwise, you write 200 pages for no reason.
So, you have to do a much more linear story
and it has to pinch at points, right?
So that you get the central story line.
So you can actually tell by looking, it'll
have to be linear and there will have to be
pinching points.
So, it's really been a cool learning experience
working on Choose Your Own Adventure, oddly
enough.
But, which will hopefully be up through Breadpig
in March.
Am I out of time?
>>Male Presenter: I think we're running out
of time.
>>Zach Weinersmith: Cool.
Thank you guys.
[applause]